Mr Popoff thank you for joining us this
is a war crime how can it be justified
actually I can tell you I I don't have
enough information about this exact case
but I can tell you what
um that Russian army isn't attacking uh
civilian infrastructure as and as I know
uh Russian missile has attacked
some of the military infrastructure in
gramators this night and I can confirm
you
um and I can tell you more about this
exact case because uh I don't have
enough information and we will see what
our ministry of defense will tell us
later in the day but I can tell you
again that Russia isn't attacked a
civilian infrastructure in Ukraine and
we should get more information about the
this exact case
so do you think are you suggesting that
Ukraine would have done this to its own
people
you know that we are at war with nature
right now and we are attacking each
other every given day uh on a
battlefield
um in uh at uh some other territories
and of course of course unfortunately a
civilians may be healed during this War
uh in Russia in Ukraine in other
territories but if you're talking about
uh attack on crematories I can tell you
again that
Russian military
not attacking civilian infrastructure if
we can see uh independent investigation
about this case we will know the truth
but uh I suggest you to wait information
from our military of Defense which which
which is there later in the day
so this is a surface to a missile that
has done this an S 300 Russia has used
them before to attack ground targets it
is a Russian missile that has done this
you're saying that it's an unreliable
missile and it didn't mean to hit this
target
you know
um we
should see and we must see what exactly
happened in parameters right now you in
the West on Sky views don't have enough
information about this case you don't
have any correspondence in in a place
you have correspondent only in key and
you can't confirm casualties Beyond uh
civilians right and I can do it easier
and we should get independent
information but I can tell you again we
not attacking civilian infrastructure in
Ukraine we are at war with the regime
and with Ukrainian Army which is armed
by Enfield by Weapon by the West
we have uh independent
monitors on the ground we've spoken to
the authorities Ukrainian authorities on
the ground Aid workers often use it let
me if I may just finish making my point
and then you please do reply uh there
are Aid workers who often use this
restaurant uh journalists that often use
this restaurant as well speaking to them
they are telling us their interpretation
of what has happened who do you have on
the ground
I do know I just told you that we have
to investigate this case and we should
get independent information about this
exact case we uh can see that Ukrainian
authorities are lying to US 24 7 and of
course every information they have they
trying to use against Russia of course
war is a tragedy for both Flags but I
can tell you again Russian side Russian
army Russian military and not attacking
civilian infrastructure and we will get
uh uh information about this exact case
so later I we can speak lately but I
don't have enough information
okay well uh we'll wait and see what
happens as far as that is concerned Mr
Popoff um is your president weak
you think so I don't think so uh we have
strong uh State institution uh we have
stable situation on our country in our
country we have stable economy situation
uh you can see on our markets they are
rising today and yesterday they Rose and
uh of course we are we've been the
witnesses of the some kind of cope or
Mutiny you can call it whatever you want
but we solve
and we're going to solve this problem we
didn't see any any Russian Elite Army uh
police or other
armed groups who
supported mutinists that's the reason
why we solved this problem during 24
hours
he's been brought to his knees by a chef
he's been brought to his knees by the
man who used to be a chef
President Putin
um there was going to be a mutiny uh his
former Chef now the leader of the Wagner
group driving up the M4 Motorway towards
Moscow you would have thought that he
would have taken him and his fighters of
the Wagner group out he's had to do a
deal and he is now in Exile in Belarus
your president has been brought to his
knees by a chef
is I sort of possessed it's uh you told
the stupid some kind of uh it's a stupid
because our president has the right and
he elected by the most of Russians he
has the rights to do whatever he wants
by our Constitution and he has right to
make decisions whatever he wants by
Constitution and we can see that it's a
situation
where we um
uh
um
don't lost uh lots of people uh and he
made the decision which is still alive
for Russians
um we solved this problem uh so quick
for 24 hours I can tell you again and I
don't see any weakness from governments
from president because soldiers from
Wagner they are heroes most of them but
precaution is a Trader
they are signing contracts with military
or defense and they're gonna continue to
fight on the battlefield with nature
tomorrow
okay thank you very much India for
joining us on the program
um as always and for being so honest and
open with us thank you